bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous comment est-ce que vous analysez la
décision de donald trump de maintenir
les troupes fédérales à portland et bien
comme il était dit dans le sujet
précédent
tu penses à une chose est sûre tous à
son élection il crée le chaos qu'ils
dénoncent par la suite et c'est une
stratégie qui n'est pas neuve
on sait très bien que nixon avait
utilisé une semblable dans le passé donc
il crée le le problème les manifestants
principalement pacifiques avaient des
revendications claires
l'intervention de la police fédérale que
nos vols ni les élus ni les uns ni les
gouverneurs des décombres est ni les
responsables la police locaux a pour
objectif de créer le désordre qui va
créer ces images ils sont utilisés la
campagne par la suite et on va essayer
de réduire le camp démocrate qui est pas
du tout gauchiste à un tout petit groupe
de gens qui l'étiquette comme étant des
anarchistes texan gauche alors qu'il
s'agit de manifestations de grande
ampleur qui réunissent des gens de tous
horizons et qui n'ont rien à voir avec
un groupuscule juste au compteur donald
trump et voit que ces anarchistes ces
agitateurs ce sont ses mots
à quelle base électorale et ce qu'ils
s'adressent alors dans toutes les
sociétés occidentales
il y a toujours une partie de la
population qui un souci d'ordre est donc
mettre fin au désordre est toujours bien
vécue par une partie de la population et
il se trouve que ces manifestations
n'étaient pas des manifestations qui
plaît le désordre
l'intervention très musclé militaire et
quelquefois de façon illégale puisque
des gens étaient kidnappés et mis dans
des véhicules non marquées par des
personnes qui semblaient être des
policiers peut-être des sodas mais qui
ne portait pas d'uniforme
crée évidemment beaucoup de colère et
attise les manifestations de protectio
notation par la suite c'est là que ça
crée donc des images de position de qui
sont appelés des émeutes par les
partisans de comme ça permet de
solidifier une base qui très fortement
secoué par ce qui se passe avec le co
vie de 19 et donc tschopp est un homme
aux abois qui est fait du cinéma
sic et ça nique pour essayer de
récupérer des voix auprès de gens qui
sont traditionnellement conservateur et
en faveur de l'or comment est ce que
vous expliquez aussi que la ville de
portland précisément soit devait
l'épidémie se devait l'épicentre pardon
de ce mouvement de contestation aux
états unis alors il ya effectivement une
tradition on va dire de protestation on
va dire de gauche pour aller très vite
mais portland ainsi que par exemple nuit
à des communautés qui sont mobilisés et
revendicative donc qui se sont mobilisés
très fortement après ce qu'il faut
appeler le meurtre de joe fly et
l'intervention de la police avait des
méthodes militaires très brutal à créer
une dynamique d'opposition et le
soubassement existe à deschamps étant
donné les légendes sont mobilisés pour
des causes sociales progressistes et
l'intervention de taux n'a fait que
l'attiser
vous l'avez évoqué en lal influence de
ces manifestations sur la campagne
présidentielle aux états unis très
concrètement comment est-ce qu'elles se
manifestent ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines voulait dire quel est
l'impact de ces magnétisation sur la
campagne
voilà alors je pense quand même que
c'est une tentative désespérée de temps
pour gommer l'effet du coville est donc
ça ça va marcher auprès d'eux un nombre
de ses partisans qui étaient très
fortement mobiliser d'autres qui sont
dans le doute mais on peut se dire
ça va être insuffisant parce que il
meurt des centaines pour des milliers de
gens tous les jours aux états unis et
dans des milieux de gens qui ont voté
pour john donc ce théâtre cynique qu'il
organise aura un effet mais à mon avis
mais évidemment on peut se tromper
ce ne sera pas suffisant pour gommer la
catastrophe du coc vide et de la gestion
proprement paul ii du présent comme sur
cette affaire merci d'avoir peu de temps
de répondre à nos questions puis on
garde un professeur de civilisation
américaine à l'université paris 10